with the global economy teetering and
some warning of a worldwide recession
the seven leaders gathering here may not
look it but they're almost certainly
worried the host Emmanuel macron and the
US president Donald Trump seemed relaxed
as they sat down on the terrace for
lunch but in addition to the china-us
trade dispute currently rattling stock
markets they have their own problems a
new French tax will target US tech
giants and Trump has threatened to
retaliate taxing French wine imports to
the US this though would immediately
receive an EU response according to the
president of the European Council I will
protect French wine with a you know
genuine determination for many reasons
and after they you stand by France if
the US imposes tariffs on France the EU
will respond in kind
president tusk is about to finish five
years in one of the EU stop two jobs a
term dominated by one issue one that
could also cause economic problems
across the continent brexit tusk warmed
the new British prime minister he could
go down in history as mr. No Deal as he
landed Boris Johnson didn't respond
directly but he did focus on his
country's future Trading prospects the
state of global trade I'm very worried
about the way it's going the growth of
protectionism of tariffs that we're
seeing the UK thrives mightily on the
open awkward-looking free trading nation
that's more gonna be promoting because
it's good for the world trade wars talk
of recession brexit it's all a very
depressing economic picture the one
thing that could bolster the markets
would be unity coming out of this g7
summit but don't expect that the French
presidency of the g7 has already said
it's not even seeking a final communique
this will be a meeting with discussion
but very unlikely to have any decisions
James BAE's al Jazeera there it's